i lupi mannari adoro i vampiri siamo
altissima alla fiera
ad aprire il nuovissimo episodio in cui
vivremo tutta la storia di Mercoledì
Addams Infatti stiamo andando nella
scuola speciale che si chiama nevermore
Ecco ci sta teletrasportando guarda che
figata Ecco stiamo per entrare nella
scuola di nevermore in cui ci sono lupi
mannari vampiri lavoro
Ehi guarda Eh dice che sto dormendo non
sta proprio dormendo sono seduta a letto
Io sono i piedi sul letto eh sono qui mi
vedi Oh no Svegliatevi è il primo giorno
di scuola il primo giorno di scuola
dobbiamo andare nel terrazzo del nonno
il terrazzo Come si chiama non mi viene
la traduzione in italiano adesso Ecco ah
ah per trasportarci Buongiorno a tutti
quanti Sono contento di vedervi dice il
principale facciamo in modo che ci siano
nuovi studenti si conoscano Ok Questi
sono gli studenti normali quindi non
sono non sono delle Creature no poi ci
sono i mannari adoro Oh
possono trasformarsi e avere le unghie
lunghe e possono fare ehm il danno extra
e poi ci sono i vampiri
voi cosa scegliereste Sceglieresti di
essere normali lupi mannari o vampiri
esistono anche le sirene in realtà no
E questa è mercoledì dove non la vedo
sono troppe persone davanti non la vedo
lei è nuova qua quindi fate in modo che
che si trovi bene nella nostra nuova
scuola Va bene andate a presentarvi Ok
ma io voglio conoscere mercoledì
dobbiamo calcolare sono tutti qua da
mercoledì Ehi spostatevi non riesco a
vederla non riesco a vederla è quella
lasciate un bel mi piace qua sotto mi
raccomando se volete vedere altri video
fate un Mercoledì Addams perché se
questo video raggiunge 5.000 mi piace
fare un altro video con Mercoledì Addams
un proveremo un nuovo gioco Ehi ciao voi
Ok da che parte eh
guardate qua Ok Segui la freccia e io
già le orecchie in realtà ma le mie
orecchie sono da gatto quindi non so se
potrei essere un gatto mannaro
Ecco mercoledì si sta qua Io invece
vicino a lei deve arrivare prima di
tutti mi hanno rubato il posto E vabbè
vado in prima fila così riuscirò a
vedere meglio aiuto Ciao a tutti io sono
la vostra insegnante quest'anno Ok cosa
ci insegnerà
qua tu dove sei qua dietro sei
all'ultimo bacio no
dall'altra parte a sinistra la tua
sinistra Ah ciao Chissà cosa ci
insegneranno Io adoro le scuole di magia
tipo Hogwarts Ma questi si chiama
nevermore troverete anche occuparvi del
mio animale domestico
è un pochino complicato da mantenere voi
avete degli animali quindi noi abbiamo
un Merlino e Circe i due Mangioni e
mercoledì dice sì Il mio animale è una
mano e si chiama mano mano
non capisco cosa faccia più schifo dice
un altro il nome Oppure che sia una mano
magari la tua mano potrebbe essere il
mio prossimo animale dice mercoledì
Ehi siate carini e il primo giorno di
scuola e il direttore ha qualcosa di che
ha pianificato qualcosa andiamo nel
giardino a vedere che Qual è l'annuncio
ok Ha un annuncio andiamo nel cortile
finora mi piace questo gioco perché mi
sembra proprio di essere nella storia di
mercoledì però aspetta stavamo in
giardino Siamo entrati in classe Adesso
ritorniamo in giardino vabbè ok è stato
molto veloce questa lezione
ok tutti qui Eccoci qua
Ok avvicinatevi tutti ok stanotte
andremo alla fiera di never Wall della
scuola Wow la facciamo ogni anno è per
questo faremo no E faremo nuove amicizie
ci divertiremo un sacco è vivo
assicuratevi di non mancare la foresta è
nella foresta No ha detto assicuratevi
di non scappare prima di allontanarvi
perché nella foresta c'è qualcosa di
favoloso
andiamo Non vedo l'ora di esplorare la
foresta paurosa vediamo anche se ha
detto di non andarci Ma sapete che noi
adoriamo le cose paurose Quindi wow
siamo altissima alla fiera Oh oh guarda
c'è il Carosello qui Che bello Voglio
esplorare io vado sul cavallo sul
Carosello Io vi controllerò ma
divertitevi
Quante giostre vediamo se riesco a
salire in questa Oh dove stai andando
Anita non mi lasciare da solo cerchiamo
mercoledì dove se n'è andato
è proprio qui sotto la ruota panoramica
la vedi Ciao ciao ciao
Come no è qui guarda qui sotto la ruota
panoramica
non entrare
nella foresta
nella foresta dobbiamo assolutamente
andare nella foresta Voglio vedere se
c'è qualche bel Lupetto mannaro da
accarezzare Ehi ragazzi
C'è qualcuno in pericolo dobbiamo
aiutarlo
aspetta Dov'è dov'è l'entrata là fuori
[Musica]
dovrebbe uscire una freccia Però noi
Ormai già sappiamo che corriamo corriamo
io prima di usare qualcuno e dobbiamo
aiutare mercoledì anche c'è un mostro
c'è un lupo mannaro sembra un troll non
è un lupo mannaro Eh tipo un troll Non
lo so che cos'è Ah okay sto eliminando
tutti ha fatto a pezzi un personaggio
Ehi Ragazzi dove siete e siamo qua che
c'è uno studente che è stato fatto a
fettine Perché non vieni qua torniamo
indietro sbrigatevi sbrigatevi Ehi ma
mercoledì Dov'è finita
non Diteglielo o potremmo finire nei
guai Beh in effetti cioè aveva detto di
non andare nella foresta gli abbiamo
mandato proprio lì e io sono ancora
nella foresta Aspetta fatemi tornare
indietro non vedo più niente solo al
buio vediamo che ti prenda quel mostro
Ok io sto vicino a mercoledì
siamo andati a investigare
Beh è il momento di tornare a scuola
adesso No io voglio rimanere
arrivati
no Panda
no Uffa Allora siamo ritornati nel
giardino della scuola è molto tardi dice
la direttrice No non voglio già tornare
tornato nelle vostre stanze andate a
dormire uffa io non voglio andare a
dormire voglio esplorare tutta la scuola
vabbè ma l'obiettivo qui ed andare a
dormire Come si fa ad andare a dormire
senza neanche aver mangiato Guarda non
capisco è vero non ci ha lasciato
mangiare proprio un bel niente lì alla
fiera
[Musica]
Cosa succede se scade il tempo forse ci
prende la creatura aiuto
Buonanotte buonanotte
Ecco la mia stanza Ehi presto andate in
giardino per arrivare alla lezione
quindi è già mattina Adesso
va bene andiamo in giardino oggi Eccoci
qua ragazzi Dobbiamo fare qualcosa
riguardo di quel mostro Non lo so Mi
sembra pericoloso
Questa è la quinta persona che ha
eliminato dobbiamo fermarla è vero
altrimenti eliminerà anche noi ok
andremo ad aiutare dobbiamo elaborare un
piano proveremo a scappare questa notte
e proveremo a trovare delle altre
informazioni
Ok va bene facciamolo credo che sarà un
po' pericoloso perché la creatura
potrebbe faccia a fette e poi ci
chiederanno tutti i robots per rinasce
re
più tardi quella notte
che stiamo facendo stiamo dormendo Vai a
tutti basta Ma dormiamo sempre questo
gioco
scappiamo adesso no non mi fa aprire la
porta non possiamo scappare ok È il
momento di scappare via freccia dove la
freccia Sto provando a uscire ma ci sono
delle videocamere che ci filma questa
roba questa mia nuova Oh no non farti
vedere delle camere di sicurezza
e la mano Vi aiuterà a trovare la strada
e in mano dove sei in mano mano mano
e non vedo niente Voi vedete mano
Ecco sono riuscita a uscire e con mano
attento devi evitare i cerchi Rossi
altrimenti ti vedranno le camere Aiuto
Aiuto
sto seguendo mano
presto presto
questo gioco
passa attraverso queste cose rosse io
non ce la faccio No non farti prendere
dalle capre Altrimenti dovrei pagare un
sacco di roba
hanno intruso umano
se ti vedono le camere ti sfracellano le
ho appena visto sì o no è successo una
persona davanti a un buon pomeriggio e
come faccio a da qui Aiuto
Non ce la faccio
non mi dire che sei stato sfracellato
solo che non vedo più niente È tutto
buio Qui dove sta mamma
è lunghissima questa parte sei stato
sfracellato lo sapevo
e fai rividi quanti robot tutti ha
chiesto 35 Uffa dai In compenso io sono
riuscita a arrivare qua da mercoledì
senza essere vista dalle camere quindi
non ho dovuto pagare nessun robot bravo
bravissimo ma siete rimasti solo in
quattro no in tre perché non ci sono
anch'io perché lui non può rivivere
Perché non ha il rombo No ragazzi
Quindi giocheremo assieme qua non so
come ha fatto a non essere presa dalle
camere neanche una volta brava Anita ma
ancora dobbiamo affrontare il mostro
finale quindi non è detto che riuscirò a
vincere secondo Zero vediamo Quale sarà
la prossima missione andiamo ad
investigare Sì adoro adoro andiamo
presto stiamo tornando nella foresta e
orari incontreremo il mostro da qualche
parte ci sarà il mostro Da che lato
andiamo mercoledì Guidaci tu Oh puoi
scendere
Non lo so sinistra Ok è destra Eh ok
Vabbè vabbè
più a destra oppure decide mercoledì e
basta guardatevi intorno eh Fatemi
sapere se avete trovato qualcosa Ok
dobbiamo cercare qualche indizio Ah ok
nell'area picnic vediamo se troviamo
qualcosa o forse ho trovato qualcosa una
spada sembra una spada sarà del mostro è
meglio che la prendiamo nel caso che
incontriamo il mostro e dobbiamo
difenderci con qualcosa
buona idea Grazie per averla trovata Ok
il resto per il resto non sembra che ci
sia nient'altro quindi andiamo
quindi sono una spada hanno trovato qua
dentro Forse era meglio andare a
sinistra allora magari c'era
qualcos'altro non lo so ma magari a
sinistra c'è il mostro meglio non
rischiare
Cosa c'è qui
una caverna o no
Scommetto che è qua che vive il mostro
abbiamo trovato la tana del mostro Penso
proprio di sì per fortuna non non
sentiamo niente Nessun rumore e siamo
venuti qui per delle risposte quindi
entriamo dentro e cerchiamone
questi mette male Secondo te cosa
succederà guarda secondo me siete in una
caverna al buio nel nella foresta di
notte che cosa vuoi che succeda
una bella sensazione
Dai non spaventarti andrà tutto bene
[Musica]
aiuto dovete sconfiggerlo attento
che lui non si sconfiggono dai
Però ho paura che poi rimarremo in pochi
Quando vedi C'è la parte Rossa Vai
attacca adesso scappa
aiuto
aiuto!che
cinque sono cinque cinque cinque di vita
vai vai vai vai 0 0 1
[Applauso]
Adesso finito il mostro Oh grande hai
preso il peggio ce l'abbiamo fatta dice
mercoledì ma qualcosa mi dice che non è
ancora finita qua tutto tutto la la
cover sta cadendo a pezzi sta crollando
da qui Ehi Ma dov'è l'uscita tu riesci a
vederla non vedo niente così Rossi che
c'hai tanto così di vita Eh sì Se mi
becca una pietra morirò qua sicuramente
uno straccio capisco
E ora cosa facciamo mercoledì Attendiamo
i tuoi ordini andate a dormire
No quella era direttrice che dice sempre
di andare a dormire si è chiusa la
caverna
C'è mancato Ciao e ritorniamo casomai si
accorgono che poi noi siamo andati via
eh Siamo scappati meglio che la
direttrice non se ne accorga siamo
tornati nel giardino Ehi ragazzi sembra
che avete avuto una notte un po' strana
e No in realtà abbiamo dormito sì certo
abbiamo avuto l'affettato una creatura
con la spada
Speriamo di avere ancora la spada e
mentre voi stavate dormendo Qualcuno ha
ucciso il
l'animale domestico del professore
come il professore
gli diciamo del mostro sì o no Non lo so
non lo so
potrei meglio non dire niente
come faremo a saperlo stavamo dormendo
come facevamo a saperlo
è in effetti è vero sto andando in
vacanza quindi siete liberi la nuova
responsabilità
state attenti all'animale che si è perso
Ma voi non pensate che veramente
l'animale domestico era il mostro vero
gigante come faceva ad essere Però
mercoledì dice non possiamo escluderlo
Ecco l'insegnante Beh ragazzi
voi siete più intelligenti di quanto
pensassi che cosa intende adesso che è
la direttrice
voi avete sconfitto il mio animaletto ma
non riuscirete a sconfiggere me oh
ma sei solo un insegnante con una
bacchetta cosa potresti farci
è diventata una strega
Ah una strega con il bastone magico
Speriamo di avere ancora la spada credo
che sia semplicemente una strega Sì
mercoledì 10 l'avevo capito
sta distruggendo tutto che sta facendo
vuole distruggere la scuola primaria
il mio piano finalmente
si sta andando Sì cioè no Non lo so No
quale sarebbe il tuo piano sentiamo
guardatevi dietro
non c'è nessuno
Ah che cos'è quella cosa verde
sta generando un sacco di potere Ma
sbaglio è diventata gigante del
professoressa strega
cattivar la scuola Sì è vero Il Gigante
dobbiamo fermarla distruggiamo tutti le
piccole queste sfere
Ok Con che cosa con la spada vediamo se
ci riesco attenta
devi essere pronta a scappare perché c'è
tanto così piccolo piccolo di vita ed è
pure rossa rossa e lentissimo Dai
sbrigati aspetta Aiuto aiuto forse è
meglio se Cominciate a farlo insieme
magari più di uno Ecco vedi brava che ti
sta aiutando Sara in due in realtà no
Zitto dobbiamo
vergognare È difficilissimo ma sempre
più difficile aiuto vai vai vai vai
piano perché non mi sono ancora
marcellata molto strana Ecco un altro
Pilastro prezzo cosa ce ne saranno di
pilastri credo che ce ne siano ancora
due questo è un altro
Rosa Brava brava brava brava brava brava
brava un altro Pilastro sconfitto Ah ce
ne sono altri manca solo uno siamo
rimasti Ok siamo ancora in treno in
gioco vedo uno sfracellato laggiù Lo
vedete Qualcuno ha cancellato Aiuto
Mi sa che sei rimasta da sola la vita no
no c'è anche una qualcun'altro No
alla fine solo uno meno male avevo preso
i robot se poi rivivere Eccomi qua sono
tornata aspetta tutto
Ecco il pilastro ah Per fortuna c'è
ancora una giocatrice con me che però fa
pochissima vita speriamo che riesca a
sopravvivere adesso arriveranno anche i
laser Rossi Ah stanno arrivando
dall'altra parte della Rossi Ti conviene
dare dall'altra parte Brava così almeno
li puoi vedere quando arrivano vai
Aspetta aspetta presto presto Oh no ma è
velocissimo è sempre più veloce la
strega la maestra strega
[Musica]
lasciate un mi piace per supportare il
fatto che sto spendendo un sacco di roba
ovunque
Dov'è dov'è il pilastro Ehi ma forse è
riuscita a succedere l'altro giocatrice
forse c'è riuscita
è tornata piccola cosa hai combinato
sembra che tu sei un insegnante normale
Dopotutto sei riuscita a prendere anche
l'altro Belgio Brava Anita Evviva E ora
che succede a direttrice è tornata sono
tornata perché ho sentito delle news che
ha delle novità Sì ma abbiamo tenuto
tutto sotto controllo posso vedere che
voi Infatti ragazzi Siete degli Eroi
Grazie per aver salvato nevermore
modestamente abbiamo salvato la scuola
buono siamo riusciti a finire il gioco e
abbiamo avuto anche la fine Quella buona
cioè che abbiamo salvato la scuola
quindi chissà come sarebbe stata l'altra
fine ma poi lasciate un mi piace E ora
vi lasciamo Qua quattro cartellini su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video che è caduto quello che preferite
eh Buona visione Ciao ciao